i am i'm titling mine chess
masters slash go patzers no monsters
yeah i think i cut my tit i forget what
i titled mine
i think it was just learning go it was
very
not bait but maybe maybe the future
youtube video
will be chess master
[Music]
struggles at learning go and you won't
believe what happens next
nice also hey chat how's it going
i don't know if akash is live but if
you're watching on my stream
um this is going to be very new so
this is a long time friend of mine a
chess master
goes by akash on twitch double a
k double a sh and
i think the plan is to learn go the only
thing i know about go is from watching
akash's streams you can still hear me
right
yeah i can hear you yeah i was just
trying to give a brief introduction
nice dude i'm i'm super excited for this
because
i have a feeling that you're going to
pick this up game up super fast
it's actually been like i can't remember
the last time i tried
like learning something completely
completely new
and just being like a complete kind of
beginner
or having kind of a complete behavior of
mindset so i'm excited because
like i've do a lot of like chess content
for newer players and i try and instill
like this sort of beginner's
uh mindset philosophy so i'm kind of
both excited but also nervous to to kind
of
experience what it's like to to be a
noob again
oh it's a very humbling experience but i
think you're going to really enjoy it
because
go is the it's a game that has like a
lot of similarities to chess
um here i'm gonna
actually go ahead and challenge you
right now i'm just gonna it's gonna just
be a casual game and then i'll kind of
explain the rules to you yeah that would
be great
because i i have not formally even
learned the rules
it's not working received
it's a challenge received okay game
started so it talks to you does it talk
to you too
yeah i have um i have a spanish voice
for mine just because the american or
english voice is kind of annoying me
interesante
yeah okay so we're playing on a nine by
nine board right now
this is kind of what people use to start
um like beginners
like kind of like mini chests or yeah
exactly
there's a great comparison but i get the
points
yeah so the game is um about just
capturing territory and the first uh
thing that i'll tell you
is unlike in chess controlling the
center is not
actually that great okay um and go
and that's because in order to capture
territory you need to surround them
and so if you think about like this e5
square you would need four stones to
surround it you would need e4
d5 e6 am i able to right click and draw
oh no
i can't draw arrows can i not in this
game
in a review gotcha i think we can but if
you look at
j9 right wait so can you repeat that you
said
when it comes to e5 to surround it you
need e4
you need the four kind of uh adjacent
square or adjacent
intersections exactly yeah so not the
diagonal ones but the adjacent got
the adjacent points versus j9 you just
need
h9 and j8 right oh yeah okay
got it so now what what's up what's the
terminology
for did you call it intersection or
points
i don't know actually i think point
by the way guys just fyi i'm not
uh eric and i are both much stronger at
chess than we already go
this is going to be a little bit like
the blind leading the blind but it
should be fair enough
at least you know the rules like i feel
like someone who knows the rules of
chess can teach someone who doesn't know
the rules
so yeah just have to stay one step ahead
exactly exactly so
i have a little more experience than you
but in this game
black goes first so oh you're yeah so
you're black
your turn to play system and what do the
black dots
what you could are there names for the
black dots or they're just kind of
um those are called likes i think those
are called star points
okay and they're just technically
they're actually um i would recommend
you start playing
there okay because it's it's kind of an
efficient use of space right you're
you're starting to develop some
influence over this corner
but you might be able to play like on so
it's a multi-purpose
exactly exactly and that's like what
this that's what this game is about it's
it's about just like multi-purpose moves
i feel like this is very historic i just
played my first ever
move and go which i i have not recorded
my first ever move in chess
it was too long ago okay so you did the
same thing
i think twitch didn't exist back then
yeah yeah we weren't recording ourselves
all the time we became narcissistic
over the ages okay so you talked about
the concept of surrounding
the the thing yeah um
and that's how you capture a piece right
like if i
so if i got pieces on c4 b3
c2 and d3 i would just capture your
piece
um yes all right yeah c4 b3
okay exactly
so you can choose to attack me but um
i have no sense of strategy so yeah i
i would just play at another one of the
star points right now
okay um because i'll trust you
you know in chess like space is a very
important concept
okay okay so i'm just going to
i'm just going to copy it i'm tempted to
like use the last star point even though
you told me
controlling the center isn't necessarily
good so that start
so that's not really a star point that's
called oh man i should i should remember
what's called the center yeah it's
basically the center
there's all these asian like japanese
terms for in go
that are kind of hard for me to remember
oh chad okay so
there's some go players in my chat
they're saying tengen or tangen
yeah okay
so um i'm just going to plot my point
there because
if it's wrong then i'll learn cool
yeah and you know it's it's not as i
don't think it's as bad
in a 9x9 game because if you look at
your g3 and g7 stones they're pretty
close to
e5 um to the tanking stone so
you can create some support so so i
imagine there's some
concept of like peace harmony even
though like they're just kind of
stationary
you want to harmonize so i'll give you
an example of a harmonizing move i don't
know if this is the best move
but you could play something like f6
where all those stones are diagonal to
each other
but those stones are actually considered
connected
um do you know why they're when i say
that do you know why they're
connected because
i mean i know diagonals aren't like
relevant in terms of capturing
but i feel like it's a strong positional
strategy because i'm seizing turret like
if you place let's say on g5 then my f6
the the wall of of g7 f6 and e5 will
will kind of block you in along the
right lines
yeah well kind of so stones are
connected when they're touching each
other right
so if when you play f6 let's say i try
to be greedy
and i try to surround your e5 stone like
i would need
e6 f5 e4
and d5 um
and oh then i can surround you back
right well
not necessarily so like five
um you could surround me back eventually
but if you're afraid of these stones
getting disconnected
you can just play at e6 so it's like if
i play f5 you'll play e6 if i play
and
so connected stones are one group so
like right now your e5 stones alone but
if you connect at e6
or f5 then i have to surround those
three stones
so it becomes it's harder to kill big
like
okay i guess i don't fully understand
the concept of
capturing or surrounding i know there's
a concept
where you have to keep at least one open
liberty
um which is like the like you can't run
out of
of adjacent spots right yeah if you if
you don't keep
one um one open liberty and you don't
have
yeah if if you're if all of your
liberties are taken up your
and your captions okay yeah so for those
that don't know
liberty is the um adjacent squares to a
group so
i'm just going to play this it's a bad
move
um okay what's your intuition telling
you about like
about that move um
well you're you're trying to invade my
territory which i already control
um my first intuition
is telling me i want to keep building
this wall
i want to play f4 to try and box you in
even more
uh it's a good idea yeah and then even
if you play something at f5 like you
haven't
you still be stuck i guess you
like you're gonna need like a long like
several moves in a row to escape
like outside the edge which i don't know
exactly i assume that it's going to come
down to some tempo
which i'm going to win yeah so well
yeah right now this yeah now this g5
stone is basically dead because
i mean i guess in theory i could keep it
alive
but in reality you have so much strength
with this like
little arrow of stones that you got
going on here
that this territory is pretty much yours
so
so even though like your your sony g5
has
all four liberties open it can't really
like it's hard to actually expand
far enough for it to be saved yeah it's
kind of like when you have a piece
overextended in your opponent's
territory
okay um you know it might not be
attacked but it's as good as that
okay and then yeah so a question about
capturing or maybe i'll get to see
but um when as
a thing is is captured it's just taken
off the board
or is it replaced by my color
that's a good question um so if you
fully
get rid of um if you fully get rid of a
group's liberties
um and it has zero liberties then it's
captured
um if you control a territory
and i can't create a living group um
and a living group i'll try to
demonstrate what a living group is with
the stones i have
okay um in a second but a living group
requires two eyes um
i i know like a a small okay
i've heard the term i before and i
assume
it's like a little diamond shape
with like a one one open
point in between yeah it's it's
yeah it's it's a it's a point that has
four of the adjacent points uh
occupied by the same color yeah so for
example
if i wanted to form an i like f6 g7
f8 and e7
i don't know if you followed that but
if i if i added added f8 and e7 i would
have a mini i
yeah you would for now um but you have
to find a way to connect all those
stones together but it would be
it would be good eye shape that's kind
of how people refer to it
okay so i really have no idea
if i should just try and capture your
piece or try and fight for more
territory
knowing that your g5 piece is probably
gonna die
i'm just gonna like go i'm gonna play a
kind of random but a move that
i don't know it's just my intuition i'm
gonna play this okay
nice i like it i like him
so what why did your intuition tell you
to play that move
um because someone is in in my chat
offering me 20 to be you and
i assume that uh i mean i want to keep
building my wall and i don't want to
give you any
any breathing room
yeah so i'm going to play this because
i'm i'm trying to connect these stones
and
if you play your stone if you played a
stone at c6 it might be a little bit
troublesome
so i'm trying to create what this is
called okay
ah now okay let me let me ask because at
some point like the board's gonna fill
up
and then i remember watching one of your
streams when you said like there's no
concept of zugsvan because you can pass
right
yeah towards any pass so
go ahead yeah so is a game won by just
having more stones another player
it's won by cap controlling more
territory
and um the stones yeah
it's just about territory that's like
the me okay that's right but
having more territory should translate
into more stones right
yeah okay it should because you need
stones to cap
to surround territory okay
so i feel like i'm already close to
controlling
more than half the board but i don't
know
yeah you've got a very good position
here i think but oh thank you you have
some
cutting points potentially um
you're playing all these diagonal moves
right but eventually you're gonna have
to connect these stones together
yeah i've i guess i
only see the value in playing diagonal
moves to keep as many
like i like i could already form an i uh
with e7
and then everything there would be safe
i'm gonna play this
and i don't know if that's good but it
looks interesting
okay cool cool i am it's a
so someone offered you twenty dollars to
win yeah shout out to braden
so so far chat has not suggested a
single move i don't think
i'd like to keep it that way i've seen
other like
streamers starting streaming chess and
then chad is always like suggesting
moves and
i assume it could be very annoying
okay i feel attacked yeah so
i'm so i'm i'm putting some pressure on
this d6 stone
but yeah remember how i said that those
diagonal stones are connected
like if i play it d if i were if you
were to pass and i were to play it d5
you can always connect you can always
keep that stone alive by playing it e6
so it's not really in but i could also
really
wait so you said e6 but i could also
keep it alive by playing at e7 right
or no um are there technologies
in this um i think we can
yeah you can offer take backs i'm just
curious so let's say you play
you want to go through a potential line
um
what was i just thinking so you were
imagining like you get another move you
have to play d5
and then i place a stone at e7 mm-hmm
uh okay this is placed in my eye
yes i can why um the reason
is you can place a stone
in a at a point that has
all the liberties taken if you're
capturing another stone
oh that okay that's important yeah and
and that's critical and that goes i'm
going to try to make two eyes
soon um but that's really that's like a
very
critical point you could have like a
really really massive structure
but if you don't have two eyes then it's
not alive yet
so like this d6 stone is safe for now
but if you don't connect to these stone
to these other stones it could be in
danger later
so let's imagine let's imagine i play
something
at e7 you play something at d5
then i have to play something in e6 to
save my d6 stone
if you want to save that okay yeah um
but maybe it just makes more sense to
play d6 and save myself
i'm gonna play v6 um e6
so one thing about go that's fun
you can sacrifice like stones kind of
like we do it in chess but i feel like
there's a little bit more nuance to it
so sometimes like
yeah i mean you could you could
definitely i openings are way more
complicated than go than chess believe
it or not
because there's so many permutations um
okay so
did we play like are there do openings
have names
and did we play like a a normal theory
i dude i'm not good enough to tell you
that but
openings in go are called
yeah i assume the branches are insane
yeah they're
they're pretty complicated again i feel
attacked
i don't know what you're trying to do
um so look at this top territory
like i've got you know these white
stones starting to influence
um and so that's one of the kind of
consequences
of the way that you played deciding to
protect this e6 stone
um there's a term used in go called like
slow play i would say uh
e6 is a little bit slow
yeah maybe it wasn't necessary yeah
exactly
and there's bigger there's bigger
territories to play for
huh okay
um by the way eric so the time control
that we played
oh i think oh i'm about to flag oh no
you're you're not you're actually not
about the flag really
um there's basically 30 30
you have five 30 second delays oh
interesting okay so that that's called
view you mean
it's actually a very cool time control i
think they're just concept so
when you say five thirty second delays
like if you burn through
one delay then you have four oh then you
just have four for the rest of the game
yeah ah oh so you could just not keep
all of them
yeah that doesn't exist in chess no it's
it doesn't and i think it's a very cool
aspect so i guess if there's like i
guess that's intended for critical
moments you want to
maybe burn through a delay exactly
exactly
okay um interesting so i i panic moved i
played d4
not knowing i was just again intuition i
want to
build another eye i guess
yeah you gotta um
i don't know if this is a good move but
i'm gonna play it just
for the walls i'm gonna play this and i
need
i really need to run to the restroom
real quick so i will be right back
feel free to my turn
okay okay chad ten i'm gonna uh
oh wait what seven why is it counting
down okay i'm gonna do this
um no idea if that was good
it wasn't counting down before
i guess i i'm still confused about this
time control
did i burn through all my delays
also what does plus 5.5
maybe his rating definitely not the
engine evaluation there's also 18k
so many questions
oh he's in he's in the forum i can't
highlight
his his pieces are in the form of the c
that probably stands for crab
there's a pause button on the right
all right oh there's so many buttons
there's zen mode
there's zen oh so zen mode ooh
i can focus now oh so i only have 30
seconds
i click it okay oh zen mode is nice
maybe i'll keep sun moon
hmm it's a little bit smaller
i don't want to make it too small
okay okay so i panicked because it was
like counting it was talking to me
and i was saying ten nine eight and then
i just play the move
you still have your five beer yummies
don't worry
but why do you have so much more time
than me because
my main time we started off with 10
minutes of mean time
and then we have the five like 30 second
delays the five video meets
ah okay yeah so
now one thing that you're gonna run into
here
okay actually i'm i'm gonna play
like just um i'm gonna play this um
one thing so the the structure you have
the shape you have here e3
d4 e5 and f4 is a flower
and it's good for making eye shape but
right now these stones aren't connected
yet
so you might want to consider trying to
connect them
okay ten nine eight
so thank you for the follow uh i assume
getting some follows from
your stream
left oh man this countdown gives me
anxiety
yeah man okay i don't understand why i
would need to connect them
if you're not moving in inside to
capture a piece almost one half a year
10. i'm just gonna block you out
again no idea if that was good but
it's not a it's it's along the right way
of thinking because
you see this like right lower right hand
corner territory
this is basically all of yours i can't
really do much about it yeah
i was thinking like maybe the whole
right side can be mine because i don't
know
i actually don't know if you can salvage
yourself
but you're dominating the whole left
side
yeah i'm also going for the sides if you
don't um
like that yeah interesting
thank you for the follows guys i
appreciate that
yeah people should continually use the
akash command oh which people are doing
that's nice
nine eight seven
six five oh we actually
i did not create the multi-stream
command for this
i should have probably done that
i can make that real quick
yeah i'm never sure what the best
approach is get that feeling of deja vu
yeah like if squad streaming is best or
um
or multi-stream or just share both the
links
okay also f9 i have no i like i
i just felt threatened and this this
goes against what i've
like the strategy of keeping my my
things together
oh you just broke up or you froze
am i in trouble okay
my internet connection is unstable
i feel like all of the the people on
your stream are just like
instantly following me now it's almost
like a video
five four three
so the reason why i said you're in
trouble yeah exactly i would have played
g9
so you froze up but then i heard the
word trouble
oh i was saying that um your f9 stone
was in trouble because i would have
played g9
but now you'll soon realize
playing at the edges is really
treacherous um
i should really turn off my alert box
i'm gonna i'm gonna oh if you have
sounds on for follows yeah that could be
you can probably turn the sound off
yeah so
i want you to think while i'm trying to
turn this off
why do you why do i say that your stones
are in trouble on the top
i mean it's like putting a knight in the
corner there's just less
like it okay in this case there's less
liberties
right exactly so what can i play to give
you only one liberty
uh h9 or g8
yeah so i would play g8
yeah oh and then you're going to capture
can you
you can capture both because there it's
kind of a group right
yeah g8 and then
this this group at the top is lost now
so that's your first lesson the the edge
of the board is treacherous
if i just play h9 doesn't save me
because you play h8
yeah you basically have opposition
exactly
10 9 8
7 six five
four three two one
hey brian the rabbit rabbit i see your
messages yeah i'm
i'm on a little bit of a different setup
than i usually am um
right now which is why i'm a little slow
to the chat but
thank you always appreciate that okay
i'm gonna just
kamikaze the top and focus on the bottom
that's a good idea
i'm playing that too i want to connect
the c3 stone to these
other two stones fair enough
i'm actually really bad at like counting
territories so i don't know
i also turned on zen mode which hi i
think it maybe hides important
information
oh actually i don't know i don't use
that oh
yeah there were some numbers i didn't
understand like it said something 8.5
or 5.5 i forget
10 9 8
seven six five
that's a throwback reference um
ben friend yeah cl thanks for posting
that we're playing on
ogs right now online go server
okay so
i think that doesn't work because uh
i feel like i'm just gonna learn from
this experience
[Music]
but now i can play oh
i like i can't play a2 because then you
capture me
if i play a4 i don't want to place on
the edge
oh you're gonna capture me anyway ten oh
that's so cruel
eight seven yeah that's stone on b3's
alone
sad three and wants to be with his
friends one
two periods left
i could play can i play a3
i'm going to try this i i doubt it works
but
i'm sensing danger that's good
that's good that you're sensing danger
your intuitions are
you're developing that's also not good
because i'm in danger
that's true okay so maybe
but i'm also not very good at this game
so that gives me hope
i could you could you could get me still
ten oh so you're throwing eight four
eight like
capturing both pieces six five four yeah
three because that group has one
liberties it's all about counting
liberty
i'm down to my last period whatever that
means
it's your last um 30 second delay so if
you run out of base you run out of time
oh okay so basically it turns into a
speed game
so now it's panic mode okay
[Music]
nice okay so i'm forced to play a4
because if i don't then you play i
capture yourself
and now i can't really oh but i can
place pieces inside
oh but there's two i guess i can never
capture you
yeah that's basically this
structures this group is alive now
because i have one guaranteed i
and uh nine a three or b three and then
i can make an eyes
six five four three
two one
you know the fun thing about go and the
time control
you can feel that one second and still
be totally fine because you get your
time back
yeah i think that's what i just did yeah
okay so
do i want to play nicely or do i want to
go in
i'll just play this
yeah the the problem with uh
b6 is
you're not gonna be able to find a way
to live there yeah
i was just trying to save my my b5 pawn
or give it some company
dude i also started calling stone's
pawns when i
when i said i call it pawn i was just in
fact like reflexive
okay so that h7 move right
um i can play
g5 but i'm not going to oh
and capture me yeah but the reason i'm
playing that is i'm kind of building off
of this other structure that starts at
g8 um and if you were to play at h8 then
i would play it h9
and then that stone would be weak you
say that one more time i played it
um if i if you were to play at h8
to instead of h6 to disconnect
i would play at h9 and i would capture
those
keystones at the top and then this h8
your black h8 stone would be weak
right okay so a lot of it
in in go it's called reading but it's
basically calculation in chess
um a lot of it's just calculating
properly i'm gonna play this
so now i'm scared like at some point
you're gonna play g6 and capture me
so i feel like i should play g6 myself
10.
so on the like on below our names there
there's like a score right
there's like so it says you have two
captures yeah i've
captured two stones so that'll be part
of the scoring process and
after the game's over i'll try to
explain the scoring
um it's pretty straightforward once you
kind of get used to it
okay i sometimes get confused sometimes
okay so i'm just gonna play this
just take my territory and go home
um
that's funny a guy in the chat
eric is very calm i think it's all the
tea he drinks
yeah i have a very big pot of green tea
nice i also made myself some ingredients
a
solid
yeah so you're going to see why these
moves won't work
which i don't know why but i assume
there there's probably a reason
yeah because like if you count the
liberties right you're trying to attack
this big group that i have right
but your c8 stone only has two liberties
it's c9 and d8
[Music]
my c8 stone has yeah okay so i'm gonna
play this because i need to attack it
and then
your c8 stone's just kind of like a
stone and you're
capturing me before yeah
i wanted to capture you
so if i play yeah well
play this
and you see now the c8 and c9 stones
i don't even need to capture them
they're they're just
lost now
oh so i can i even place a stone on d9
or no nine no eight because that would
be uh suicide
five four three two
one so by the way the term for when
a stone uh stone is played that gives
another group only
one liberty that's called atari it's
kind of like
jack from chat stone is play that gives
another group one liberty okay
so like when i played b9 right my c
group
yeah that's the one d nine okay
yeah like this
okay so we can never oh so i just used
atari against view by playing g4
yeah yeah but
you don't even need to capture that
stone that stone's lost
no pretty much uh-huh
because your group has been more than
two eyes now
so you're you're you're sick right
eric you are playing kind of tricky
aren't you i just want to capture your
three things i'm gonna try to keep them
alive
oh so if i place j9 you can place h9
even though you're putting a thing in my
thing you're capturing my thing yeah
because j9 doesn't capture my group
right because
i have not yet i have j5 still eight but
i can do this
and now i'm so if i don't let you
if i don't do anything here you're gonna
play
j9 and kill that group
right so i have i'm forced to play h9
now and then i get
these three stones so i'm gonna play
oh you capture oh i forgot you capture
h92
or h8 yeah yeah uh
oh that's so sad
and you have the eye oh you have so many
eyes
yeah i have a lot of eyes okay i'll
capture you back
okay so
i'm going to i don't think there is any
useful moves left
i feel like we're just you pass
yeah you don't want to like satisfy
yourself by filling your
your first rank no because actually that
would just be a um
you would lose points for that really
because like
a stone a stone on a point that you
already
have 10 is a waste
because territory
wait so you get more points for using
less stones
yeah oh oh so you'll have to explain the
scoring in more
more detail then right so like look at
your
look at your lower right hand corner
that is all of your territory
so there's no reason to play g1 i should
have passed
um or maybe i could have fought for
yeah i would say before i was like sorry
yeah there there was uh that that move
didn't really do anything but all this
is your territory and i can't really do
anything about it because you have eyes
at
um g5 e4
f3 so yeah i mean you have way more than
two eyes so this stuff is all alive
um so i'm gonna pass again
so where where is the score first of all
um the scores
i think there are certain sites where
you can see it but they don't show it to
you right now
and you just kind of have to judge yeah
and what is that like how do you figure
it out move the dead stones
so this is the point in the game where
the scoring occurs
oh um so now you see on your screen do
you see like a bunch of
rec or squares yeah
okay so so it's defining your territory
exactly and so do you uh do you
understand why
the upper left-hand corner your black
stones are mine yeah because they're in
your territory and i can't save them
yeah you can't you can't make a living
group um
if you were able to somehow create two
eyes with those two groups
then that would be your character but
because you couldn't
i was too close to the edge yeah
so at this point you just press accept
remove stones
and then the game is over white wins oh
so and so i won by 22.5
points um let's just talk about the
scoring real quick yeah i see the
computer graph
yeah exactly um so i was better at one
point when you played your uh
was this g5 move yeah g5 was a bad move
um
but let's just talk about the scoring um
so black makes the first move right that
has somewhat of an
advantage right um
to make up for that there's this concept
called
comey which is a certain number of
points
that white is given to make up for that
so if you see on my under my name
there's
like plus 5.5 i was showing that earlier
now i just say i see 54.5 points
okay so before it said plus 5.5 that's
kind of
what i'm given to make for
my uh the fact that i didn't move first
gotcha so you add 5.5 that's how i got
54.5
and i scored i had five captures so
that's
five more points so that's 10.5
and then now if i count my territory
i have if you count the territory and
you count also the stones in the
territory
um your c9 and c8 stones those points
are
two points each for me because it's a
capture and it's territory that i have
oh so you get point you get additional
points for capture
okay yeah so
let's just count my territory i have j9
h82 g9 f94
e8 d9 uh six
um c9 and c that's four points to
[Music]
a9 through a5 that's 15.
b7 through b5 that's six
so 21. um i'm just going to
the the lower right hand left hand
corner 22 23 24 25 26
27 i trust that it adds up i feel like
this would be
important information to know like
during the game
did that not add up i it's not adding up
for me
i don't know why um so we have to count
okay so we count everything within your
territory plus the captures
that's it right yeah
uh plus a extra 5.5 because that's the
extra 5.5 down
okay so how many oh it's nine by nine
right
i put the wrong type of scoring twenty
that's fine
i put chinese scoring oh oh it was
different okay so it's
a different system yeah it's a different
system
so normally in japanese scoring um
it should add up there's like different
ways of playing this game
um there's chinese scoring japanese i
think there's like canadian
i don't remember the other ones but the
most common one that you'll play with is
japanese and
essentially the rules that i described
that's how you would play it
okay so are you ready to go again
i think so but okay so
are we gonna play with the japanese like
the the normal
scoring that you just explained yeah
like you can send me a challenge
yeah okay and then
so when you so when you play are you
you're not keeping track of score you're
just kind of
sensing if you're controlling more
territory
yeah it's probably not the right thing
to do okay
but that's kind of how i assume like
very strong players will
always have a sense of the exact score
yeah they will like the uh the best
player as well
um i'm gonna make the main time 15
minutes a little bit longer just
because i think it's just about getting
that intuition yeah
this looks good challenge received
challenge received
game started okay i think i accepted
oh thank you you're great for the
subscription i appreciate that
oh yeah shout out to brayden too hello
streamer
okay so i'm gonna investigate 5.5
yeah really novelty
yeah it's it's a garbage move but
yeah that's good i just want to
see how you play you're showing me mercy
i don't think i'm good enough to really
show mercy mm-hmm
oh you're just going to be like normal
level okay
i mean not really but yeah
i feel like the center is important if
you want to control
like be most multi-purpose
i don't know though
in 9x9 the center is a little bit more
important
because you know it can build the
framework for
uh covering the corners and the sides
does it go smaller than 9x9
i don't think so
we can try well so there's nine by nine
then there's 13 by 13 and the most
common one is 19 by 19. um
those games yeah that's the main that's
the main one so nine man is kind of like
a little bit
easier
so we're we're all social distancing our
pieces i don't know this is like a
strategy
yeah attacking and go is a little bit
different from in chess i think in chess
it's a little bit more confrontational
and go you only want to attack
it's like passive aggressive yeah
maybe that's an artifact of
i don't know the history of the game
okay play here
okay
so a lot of the tasks behind uh
making living shades is just being able
to create those eyes so yeah
i think f6 is a very good move thank you
always play f6
new e-mode idea i i have an f6 bam emote
in contrast to feingold's never play f6
emote
i don't mind playing outside
that's always a good move okay so
i plenty oh so much time that's nice
yeah
okay so i feel like you're being
confrontational
i don't know if you want to play f7 or
you're just trying to still do your own
thing
so usually a good rule of thumb is to
connect your stones so
i think f7 is a worthy move to consider
yeah i feel like it's just
the safest like don't don't mess with my
territory
i'm gonna play this oh wow
but it's another emo worthy move
yeah okay so i'm looking for ways to
make an
eye i'm gonna play
let's do this
so one thing i want you to kind of think
about as you're trying to make eye shape
here
is how to
make sure your stones are connected
while you're making eye shapes so like
you're probably thinking of d6 right
exactly yeah yeah um
and i think d6 is a good move but you
just have to find
a way to just make sure your d4 stone
remains connected
to the rest of your stones gotcha
they should be but you're not
threatening so like i i can always
it has all four liberties right now so
yeah if you ever make a threat i can i
can probably defend
yeah so what i'm gonna
do is okay i'm just gonna play this one
room
okay and then i'm gonna try to
i'm gonna create some eye shape just to
show you how to how to make it
interesting okay
play
try this nice
okay capping me yep
limiting the movement of this group i
like it i like that
okay so i'm gonna play this
so i feel like your your corner move it
just gave me
it's as if i'm playing i i have the
first move and i have extra points
yeah right um the concept of like
tempo and tempe in chests and
go it's called scenting so kind of
having the initiative um so yeah a9 is
a horrendous move
conflicted where to go
i think i'll go c4 explosive
wow because i just i wanted to connect
them
so i've basically absorbed two things
make make the eye shape
so i basically have two eye shapes and
then
when i have the eyes or at least so many
on the diagonal i want them connected
so they're not in danger yeah those are
two very big learnings you're you're
gonna make it far in this game
[Music]
they'll be better than these i don't
know anything beyond that
that's basically all i know too okay i'm
kidding
sort of not really
so i feel like i want to place
something at h8 but then it starts
becoming complicated because then we're
kind of
it can come down to tempe
i don't know what's happening there i
think it's it's fine
um the problem is like if you don't play
it [ __ ] i'll play h8 and i'll start to
kind of creep in
to your territory but yeah you have to
be able to calculate it
yeah i can imagine this is where
calculation comes into play
yeah that's why i wanted to increase the
time to make it a little bit
easier for me to try to calculate for
sure
um yeah i'm realizing like your
your four in a row wall
is actually quite annoying because then
i can't can't easily
infiltrate yeah that's called i
i think i mentioned this in the first
game that's called thickness
and um basically because i have all this
thickness with this connect four group
i can't really break it yeah it's very
difficult to break like i have one two
three four
five six seven eight liberties so
i can kind of safely assume that it'll
be live
it'll stay alive and then the territory
around it should be mined unless you're
able to invade
i'm going to play h8 i feel like this is
prophylaxis but it's also
going to get complicated oh yeah i think
it can get complicated quickly
[Music]
assuming i don't just tragically blunder
okay so don't tell me if i'm i'm wrong
but i'm just going to think out loud
i'm calculating h6 and then
you take away my spot i probably just
end up losing a piece
that's probably no good
but maybe
huh
wondering if i can just
i try the gym just opened recently let's
try this
okay so you were talking about age six
right um let me give you just a quick
tip on when you're calculating that um
so pretend j8 is not there right
okay when you're playing h6 you're
trying to attack
my group at um h7 and jj7 right
the thing about that is when you play
your stone at h6
you have two liberties of j6 and h5
yeah and then you you just get the move
and you start taking away
exactly because my group also has two
liberties but since i get the first move
there
i'm able to deal with this when the
round before it's a problem
but now if you were to play h6 but
if i were to pass you could play h6 and
then this
uh i'm threatening uh
oh interesting yeah because i'm
threatening
i'm basically threatening to play h6 and
then if you play j6 i play j5
exactly and capture your three okay
exactly
you're learning yeah so you prevent that
yeah no wow so it's gonna be impossible
to capture you because you're so
thick i'm very thick
this is a thick voice club so i feel
like this is just uh
we're just kind of now doing our own
thing
um maybe i can thicken myself
i feel like knowing the score here would
be nice
well you know a9 is like two points for
you pretty much
that's true it's good to know
okay um
[Music]
i feel like um i'm starting to
understand some
like that that calculation but in terms
of just general positional play
uh might just resort to making eyes
so what is like what is territory that
we're still contesting
oh that's actually that's a good
question that's probably a very relevant
question
yeah because the whole bottom is seems
like yours
but maybe like the center between f4
e4 f5
but i don't want to get captured
remember what i was saying about
connected stones
oh yeah yeah it's hard to capture
yeah connected stones yeah
so if you were to play it like f4 right
yeah i'm actually considering f4
because then if i get f4 f
no oh i always if i play f4 i can always
connect via
f5 or e4 so it's never in danger
okay so let's do that yeah yeah and
that's it
that actually reduces the uh
that reduces my territory a little bit
so okay
i'm gonna play this
and so okay so now you're threatening to
play f5 and basically just win my piece
yep close the door i'm debating
between f3 or f5 myself
intuition's telling me to play f5
because f3 you play f5 and then i'm
stuck with
two which are
quickly running out of space so i'm
going to do f5
awesome yeah so one rule of thumb and go
is if it's your opponent's turn
and they were to make a move often times
that's a good place for you to put your
stone
uh interesting okay it's a very useful
rule yeah that rule doesn't exist really
in chess
no it doesn't at all but okay the
concept of like prophylaxis
and chess maybe it's a bit more
complicated because you identify what
your opponent wants to do
but then that doesn't involve you
actually playing that same move
usually not because something's going to
get captured yeah
okay so i'm going to play f3 okay so now
you're extra thick
but so am i yeah
okay so i'm gonna ask myself the same
question what territory
are we contesting for i'm looking at b3
but that feels risky because then you
what what is what is it called atari
tamaki atari
atari atari okay
well yeah if i play b3 you play a3 and
you atari me
and then i probably lose i run out of
space
um if you play b3 i'm gonna
play b2 instead because remember i want
to drive you to the edge of the board
where you have less liberties fair
enough
it's like anybody in my chat if if
there's
any points that you think i should try
to explain to eric
let me know again i'm not
that great at going either but i'll try
to
be as helpful as i can okay
cool a7
i assume the main focus is like the
the left upper
upper left quadrant yeah
yeah and like the sides um
i don't know what the best move is here
i'm gonna play this which looks kind of
weird
okay
now i'll connect
i feel like you're controlling a little
bit more territory but i'm gonna capture
your piece
i have the extra
five i feel like it's just gonna come
down to score
yeah so do you see any useful moves for
you here
well i want to capture your piece right
or no i don't
you don't want to capture my piece
because it's already yours wait so how
so how does the scoring work
i guess we didn't address like if more
pieces are on the board
so with this a9 stone
it's not alive because i don't have two
eyes here yet right
and because all this territory on the
top
is yours this stone on e9 is considered
um it's considered to be dead yeah okay
um now if i were to get like
let's say i were to get a bunch of moves
in a row
and i was able to play something
ridiculous like
a8 through e8
and then e9 and c9 i would actually have
a
strong a8 through e8 oh okay
so those five points combined with c9
and
then you have two eyes and i can't i
can't do anything
yeah do you know where the eyes are in
that in that
hypothetical structure uh b9 and d9
exactly so in that country yeah
yeah that would be a living that would
be a living shape
but in reality like i can't i don't have
enough time to make those moves but yeah
i'm always going to capture you yeah
yeah yeah
so i feel like so let's say
i just play something randomly on j9
rather than passing
how would that affect my score do i just
not like
is it just an empty these empty
intersections or empty points that i get
scored for
or do i get score for the the pawns that
i placed down
from the pawns in place yeah um
the uh it's the it's the empty territory
so
okay got it okay so right now i'm i'm
counting yeah
so i would have 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 and then
uh i have 21 but i also have your 89 so
i have 22
if i'm counting that correctly
i thought you had 23 but let me just
double check okay
well it's actually really close
17 24 i count 23 but i might be wrong
one two three four five six
plus 9 is 15 plus
7
i'm counting 22 still i don't know maybe
i just can't count
1 two three four five it doesn't really
matter because it's going to count for
us
but then you have yeah i get lazy
sometimes yeah
so your first two ranks are 18
22 okay so that's 20
one two three four five six seven you
have 27.
oh i just made a realization
so the 5.5 actually really matters
because there's no draw
like the 0.5 of the 5.5
um allows or makes it so there's no
draws ever
right yeah and yeah so i if i'm counting
correctly i'm winning by half a point if
i just
pass me pass i
um i i just made that realization too i
forgot about the comey
and wait what's kill me
it's the 5.5 oh 5.5
it's kiyomi or comey call me
comey okay
all right i think it's moved
did i 27.00 that was white yeah hey i
won
let's go i feel so accomplished i
it is i think it is 23 right because
um top row is nine next row is seven so
16
17 18 19 20 wait
this oh yeah 20 21 22
and then my one stone one two
three four five six so i uh
so not including rows eight and nine
there's six right yeah then six
plus row nine that's 9
right so 6 plus 9 is 15.
and then plus 7 is 22
but then you get one point extra for the
black for the capture
oh i just included that as an empty okay
so got it
okay and that's why you don't that's why
you don't need to surround this stone
right because
you would get one point per capture
um and that would be that
you'd be subtracting two points because
those are two points of space that
you're modifying okay i i think this is
beginning to make sense
um yeah like i had counted
because i didn't count the capture i uh
i assumed it was going to be 27 to 27.5
so this is slightly less dramatic yeah
congratulations on winning your first
game thank you